hier sind die pancakes wir fangen an mit
einem unten dann eine parkscheibe dem
nächsten pancake der nächsten pub
scheibe und einem letzten pancake also
die pappel ist jetzt hier drin und das
wirkt direkt ja mal ein bisschen größer
denn jetzt kommen halt auch schon das
motoröl ich bin jetzt wirklich mal
gespannt ob das besser aussieht
[Musik]
hey was geht ab märz willkommen bei
einem neuen video leute 1 könnt ihr mir
glauben diese videos sind super
aufwendig man denkt das vielleicht gar
nicht weil alle sachen china ist hier so
und ich kann direkt anfangen aber bis
das erst mal so weit ist dass ich
wirklich alle sachen hier ich war drei
mal im supermarkt bei mir dann immer
aufgefallen ist exakt das was du noch
vergessen
das hast du noch vergessen als ich bin
jetzt wirklich froh dass ich hier sitze
und das video drehen kann wollte gibt es
nämlich den zweiten part von essens
tricks wie sie in der werbung oder
beziehungsweise in der fernsehwerbung
benutzt werden natürlich auch ein
bisschen im internet überall in jeder
werbung wenn zum essen geht kommt halt
so was vor und der letzte pass ist nicht
gekommen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht macht
einfach ein zweiter eine sache wollte
ich noch sagen und so habe ich unter dem
letzten video oft gelesen dass das ja
kopiert das aus amerika und das stimmt
das habe ich auch in einem video gesagt
also die meisten sachen die wir heute
test hat auch irgendjemand schon mal in
amerika gemacht ganz ganz viel ein user
namens raphael kommen ist der dass aber
auch alles von der website hat von der
ich das auch habt weil ich meine ist
kann man sich als einzelne person ja gar
nicht alles ausdenken wie will man denn
die information hier haben also da gibt
es webseiten wo ganz viele tricks für
werbungs essens geschichten aufgelistet
sind und habe ich meine ideen auch alle
her kann ich euch auch sehr gerne meine
bestimmung verlegen ich habe heute
insgesamt fünf tricks vorbereitet einmal
haben wir ja einen pancake trick wie
sehen pancakes möglichst lecker aus wir
machen was mit dampf wir machen was mit
eis ja auch ganz ganz wichtig wir machen
was mit bürgern
wir machen was mit himbeeren wir machen
was mit schuhcreme also wahrscheinlich
denkt da ich gerade so what the [ __ ]
aber ich kann euch eines versprechen es
wird lustig und vor allem sehr
interessant ich hoffe natürlich es
klappt alles falls mir etwas nicht
klappt ist das so aber ja pech gehabt
leute wir fangen erst mal das relativ
leicht im an einem dafür brauchen wir
diesen wasserkocher ich muss jetzt
heißes wasser machen ich habe hier eis
und salz damit es funktioniert das fehlt
einfach noch ein bisschen dampf was wir
machen das eigentlich ziemlich leicht
wir tun hier in dieser schälchen ein
bisschen 12 man muss ja sagen jedes es
in der werbung das dampf so schön aber
das darf ja nicht weil es heißt es so
das kann ja nicht drei stunden dampfen
so das reicht auch schon ein bisschen
eis habe ich so viel gekauft aber für
die heißen temperaturen die wir daraus
nahmen eine perfekt so jetzt durch ein
bisschen salz hier rein damit wir es
noch kälter machen und jetzt passt mal
auf ich habe hier nämlich diese pancakes
die werden jetzt gleich schön dampfen
zumindest in meiner anderen kamera dicht
damit positioniert habe jedoch eben ein
schwarzer hintergrund damit man das
dampfen sieht leute ist gar nicht
schlimm wegen die wir zum nächsten trick
der wird bestimmt klappen teufel gleich
habe ich noch was spezielles mit diesem
kuchen vorher so auch ein trick der ist
wirklich auch interessant hab ich mir
auch selber was zu einem verlassen wir
machen jetzt allerdings erstmal weiter
habe mit diesen beiden werken hier ja
ganz normale cheeseburger gekauft in
irgend einem supermarkt meines
vertrauens aber ich muss ja auch direkt
schon sagen wenn ich mir die bürger an
kugel die davon auf der verband sind und
das was hier drin ist ein kleiner
unterschied aber wir schauen jetzt
einfach mal ob ich das was hier vorne
auf der verpackung ist nicht hier
rausholen kann das wollen wir eigentlich
nur ein messer und schuhcreme also
wirklich echte schuhcreme die bürger
manchmal müssten natürlich erstmal
eigentlich noch im backofen also
schlecht aussehen tut es natürlich auf
keinen fall
ich schaue jetzt allerdings mal was ich
da noch rausholen kann erstmal ganz
wichtig in jeder bürger werbung sticht
er so dieses burger petit raus also es
ist nicht darunter das muss wirklich zum
vorschein kommt deswegen können wir das
ganz einfach so machen wir schneiden
hier
stückchen raus da sieht man gleich eh
nicht mehr
dann teilen wir das hier so ein bisschen
auf zack legen meinetwegen den käse
wieder darüber
und ich glaube der unterschied kann man
in dieser kamera mit dem man dann
theoretisch auch die werbung drehen
würde
ganz klar sehen das fleisch wird er
sicherlich forschung gebraten man muss
allerdings sagen so richtig lecker sieht
das nicht aus fleisch muss ja auch mal
so ein bisschen schwarz sein so ein
bisschen an muss sehen dass das wirklich
gegrillt wurde zumindest empfinde ich
das so deswegen nehmen wir jetzt ein
bisschen schuhcreme und jetzt bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt ob ich das
hinkriege wie es mir vorgestellt habe
schuhcreme kommt einfach so ein bisschen
hier drauf wichtig heißt es erstmal hier
oben
ich war mir unsicher ob vielleicht
schwarze noch besser ist deswegen habe
ich einfach mal dunkelbraun genommen
aber ich finde es sieht auf jeden fall
nicht schlecht aus ich bin ja noch gar
nicht fertig
[Musik]
leute der unterschied ist heftig ich
würde sagen das reicht jetzt schon ihr
könnt es ja schon sehen also in der
kamera
wir haben hier einmal vorher und nachher
wenn jetzt noch der käse darüber
verläuft dann sieht das wirklich schon
lecker aus also das finde ich ist
wirklich verrückt dass man für so was
halt schuhcreme verwendet damit es so
aussieht so wer kommt darauf ich werde
niemals in meinem leben drauf gekommen
ich finde es hier vielleicht immer ein
paar beauty shot und dann gehen wir über
zum nächsten heck aber dann würde ich am
liebsten essen in börger ich habe jetzt
gerade bei dem du dich noch mal gesehen
das ist vielleicht noch besser wäre wenn
die schuhcreme wirklich schwarzes aber
ich finde das ist jetzt möglich auf
hohem niveau deswegen ich bin auf jeden
fall mit meinem ergebnis dann zufrieden
gewesen dann weiß ich auch noch sagen
wollte an alle die schreiben ja das ist
doch voll die lebensmittelverschwendung
natürlich ist das in gewisser weise doof
wenn man den bürger wegschmeißen weil
man ihn ja nicht mehr essen kann ich bin
auch kein fan davon lebensmittel
wegzuschmeißen allerdings spart euch
doch einfach diese kommentare wenn ich
sowas hier sehe ich will meine decke
rewe lidl aldi die schmeißen jeden tag
so viel tonnen lebensmittel weg und ich
zeige euch hier so ein paar futacs hier
zur unterhaltung dienen dann finde ich
ist sowas auch mal okay aber da hat
natürlich jeder seine eigene meinung so
wir machen weiter mit eis also wirklich
mit eis zum essen ich habe keine ahnung
ob das klappt weil ich habe nur videos
gesehen haben dass welche mit anderen
substanzen ausprobiert als ich das heute
machen wir also nicht substanz nicht
keine drogen das sind ja auch substanz
das glaube ich auf jeden fall haben wir
hier einmal als das steht jetzt auch
schon ein bisschen länger herum und man
kann direkt das problem sehen
es schmilzt und ist natürlich verdammt
schnell vor allem wenn es dann in der
waffel ist oder so schmeckt aber
wirklich gut ok reicht auch jetzt wenn
man dann wirklich im eis kreieren will
ich habe das im internet gefunden kein
plan ob das klappt benutzt man
kartoffeln also man für die werbung im
eis trainieren möchte ich habe mir hier
mal eben kartoffeln gekocht so sieht es
aus die wir jetzt erstmal zerstampfen
das machen wir schnell die mit der
zahnpasta die wir gleich auch noch
brauchen
so die sind jetzt halbwegs zerstampft
dankeschön
jetzt braucht man ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe ich nehme einfach mal
pink verein mit dir also haben wir so
eine maske sieht aus wie erdbeere die
kugel muss ich jetzt leider wird meine
hand vorm aber kein problem
ein bisschen farbe kommen noch oben
drauf so ich bin so wichtig und ich bin
echt zufrieden bevor ich euch das jetzt
zeige warten wir mal fünf minuten um
auch den unterschied zu erkennen ich bin
natürlich auch kein profi und jetzt
gerade muss ich ganz klar sagen dass das
echte eis eigentlich sogar besser
aussieht aber es hält nicht so lange und
bei dem kartoffel zeug
ich bin glaube ich werde ich ja erst das
so ausprobiert hat wenn man das jetzt
irgendwie zeigen würde würde er
sicherlich denken das ist eine eiskugel
ist und dass solche erreichen irgendwann
später
so also das war das eis und die
kartoffel erst entsteht so eine sauerei
ist wirklich unglaublich wir kommen
jetzt allerdings zum letzten und zu
meinem trick auf wen ich mich am meisten
freue
den habe ich auch schon öfter auf
youtube gesehen zumindest halt alles auf
englisch oder amerikanisch wir machen
das heute trotzdem ich habe mir sirup
besorgt ja aber oder was hab ich dann
dass sie ihre bis dato und sirup und
motor will ja also wirklich echtes
motoröl und dann habe ich heute pancakes
gebacken
so sehen die aus dann habe ich auch
schon selber gegessen wirklich sehr sehr
lecker so pancakes ist man ja mit sirup
oder ahornsirup
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal
an so sieht es bei jedem aus wenn er
sich selber pantex macht und diese dann
mit sirup übergießt
[Musik]
ich muss sagen mir gefällt so viele es
sieht echt lecker aus aber es soll wohl
noch besser gehen
und dafür brauchen wir halt dieses
motoröl also wirklich stumpfes motor er
gut eine sache die sieht man hier der
sirup ist jetzt komplett runter gelaufen
also da ist gar nichts mehr wirklich
drauf deswegen wenn ich jetzt mal umso
mehr auf den trick gespannt dafür
brauchen wir zahnstocher wir brauchen
ein bisschen pappe und halt das mutter
hier sind die pancakes wir fangen mit
einem unten dann einer parkscheibe dem
nächsten pancake der nächsten pub
scheibe und einem letzten pancake also
die pappe ist jetzt hier drin oder das
wirkt direkt ja mal ein bisschen größer
denn jetzt kommen dort auch schon das
motoröl ich bin jetzt wirklich mal
gespannt ob das besser aus sie eine
ahnung
es riecht auf jeden fall nicht lecker so
leute
okay okay also das sieht wirklich faktor
alter das sieht mégane eis aus ok jetzt
schenke ich den unterschied bauen wie
das darunter trug das war jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen viel
aber wir machen mal ein paar beauty shot
und dann sieht man direkt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja heute also wir können sehr gerne
kommentieren weil jedoch dass hier
schöner finden aber ich muss sagen das
ist wirklich der krasseste unterschied
so ich sitze jetzt wirklich schon sehr
lange das video wo ich nehme selten so
lange hat jetzt über eineinhalb stunden
gedauert
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wenn ihr
sagt hey mach bitte noch ein paar gibt
einen fetten daumen nach oben
dann sehe ich das ja und ja dann kommt
das zunächst ich muss jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen aufräumen steckt auf jeden fall
instagram ab eigentlich wollte ich noch
ein handy mit dem kuchen den mache ich
jetzt ins nächste video weil sonst
einfach viel zu lange wir leute es hat
spaß gemacht hat ein